Jamie Foxx with Jamie how's he what have
you heard how's he doing I'm praying
yeah yeah you see I posted on Instagram
like I literally been saying prayers out
loud yeah words of affirmation for my
big brother uh and uh we're actually so
much I know he's doing so much better
because
um I'm actually uh about to do something
special for him uh and doing him a favor
so we know things I can't really say
what it is but it'll be out there soon
but uh it's definitely where uh I was
reluctant to to go all the way there and
even talk about it but he gave me the
blessing so it's it's a it's a beautiful
thing he's awake he's he's uh and you
know they say he's alert so we love it
all right that's great that is good
that's family that's family right there
by the way you said you told Howard
Stern the rock and roll love all their
siblings having the siblings they do
family how is that for them man it's
cool and their their birthday is
actually uh next week you remember you
came to uh Six Flags yes I is the very
beginning yeah where me and Mariah and
we shut it down I'm doing that for that
birthday again this year you're gonna
shut it down next week and you know what
was funny about that day is people
didn't think Nick Cannon could shut down
yeah
right Mariah did I was like I was like
y'all Nick did it he's got a lot of jobs
he's making money
man that was that was more than 12 years
ago maybe like 14 years ago yeah yeah
what a great it was a great day it was a
great day I want to ask you a quick
question breathe he's going to be on
selling something yes have you talked to
her about what I just reposted that on
my uh Instagram story that trailer is
fire they brought her in at that after
the end I was like oh the boss lady
showing up y'all gonna get to see the
breed that I know and love
what breed will we see She Don't Take No
Mess I think I mean like I was I never
watched Southern Sunset before this but
just checking out with y'all like she
she gonna she gonna do her thing on
there so I'm excited for it rise and
shine or shall I say rise and grind is
Nick Cannon here and I'm super excited
to announce my new show on the amp app
it's called The Daily Cannon oh yeah
live and unfiltered the daily Cannon
tell me tell me about the daily Cannon
man I'm super excited about this because
as we know I mean I was working my butt
off in Harlem for the Nick Cannon show
yes and I sat there even in like my
first month I was like yo it takes 16
hours to do one hour of content as we
both know I don't have the bandwidth all
the time for that you have a lot of jobs
yes a lot of jobs yes and so I was like
how can I do this
exact thing have this same Vibe be my
authentic self and uh less amount of
time and they created this uh app with
Amazon called amp that allows me to do
all of that so not only do am I doing a
talk show a radio show it's really
embodying my life all at once from 6am
to 9am every morning and it just said
like this is this platform form was
built for me because it allowed me to
consolidate all my morning radio stuff
that I was doing every day and that was
a lot yeah all my talk show stuff that I
was doing every day okay so how will you
cover the news on the show because
you've said yes you can put it all out
there all the way out there I mean we
got we got uh still got segments that
you know I don't like to call them hot
topics but it's really like my take on
what's going on in pop culture so uh but
then more than anything we're not just
covering pop culture we creating pop
culture yeah moments was gonna be
interviews obviously we got DJ Abby De
la Rosa we got uh Courtney beef and wild
and out Mason on the mic from Tick Tock
so we got a team of queens that are
literally just gonna be talking that
talk every morning they they handle the
gossip I stay out to God oh you're gonna
stay out of the Gospel I was about to
throw you deep in it right now
um first of all Abby being a part of the
team that's kind of cool to keep it in
the family absolutely man I mean I mean
you'll get to see our bond you'll get to
see you know why so much love there and
I mean she's the mother of three of my
children but I met her in the space days
of her working at I Heart Radio man and
I always was a fan of hers and I was
like yo this is she she's allowing
herself to soar it's still you know by
we we got the nanny we I got a nurse oh
you've been to the nurse so the kids the
kids would be upstairs while we're
downstairs doing the show will we ever
see the kids will the kids ever see
mommy and daddy working so I think
exactly right especially I mean like
because the twins are running around all
over the place so they love they love we
call literally our Studios called the
playroom so it's toys everywhere it's
bright colors so yeah they'll definitely
pop in what kind of folks will you
bringing for the show oh man I think are
we kicking it off you know keeping it
music Centric so we kicking it off next
week with uh nle Chopper you know young
man that I'm a huge fan of I believe my
brother Swiss beats got a new project
coming out uh but it's anybody man I'm
really I'm trying to get Taylor Swift to
pull up well talk to her tell her right
now
we need you on the daily Cannon we got a
lot to talk about uh I'm trying to get
the magic like uh Kevin when it comes to
my interviewing skills I won't get too
much into your business because I know
it's a lot going on but we need Taylor
Swift on a daily Cannon that'll be
beautiful you just did a movie with Alec
bone yeah yeah okay hold on tell me
about that because I'm I'm putting you
to the test yeah yeah yeah he is uh my
man uh I've been you know supporting him
uh just as one as a fan man he's yeah
he's one of the greats but then
obviously the unfortunate and tragic
situation that uh he was in in the
middle of that man like when when things
like that happen all you can do is pray
for your friends and your colleagues and
the prayers were answered yeah but how
hard is that for someone to try and
focus and work while they're dealing
with something and that was the
Brilliance of it and once you see our
film which is called uh Hollywood Heist
you'll see that it's the inner workings
of Hollywood so he's almost playing a
very similar like character and the film
has this like Big Lebowski Pulp Fiction
type of vibe so like I don't want to
give too much away but my character uh
who is an agent is trying to convince
one of the greatest actors of all time
to be in the film for one of his clients
wow so y'all had a lot of fun yeah I'm
sure it was a great kind of relief for
him or release yeah man it got got it or
gave him the opportunity to take his
mind off of some very serious stuff that
was going on his mind because when we
were making it you know he was in the
midst of all of that so uh prayer shouts
out and loved him I can't wait for
people to see the film how
much you got right now how many projects
yeah does Nick Cannon have right now
yeah probably if we just gonna go shows
that are currently on air we're gonna go
as like six to eight yeah yeah how do
you fit all that in and you work out in
the morning every I work out three a.m
every morning
yeah so that's crazy because I got to be
ready I got to be prepping daily Cannon
by 5am
because we we are cracked the mics at
six when is the nap uh there's a few
naps naps usually around 12 or one like
I'll take naps with my babies take naps
oh so you're going to eat when they go
let's go to sleep yeah yeah so they go
to sleep around seven sun down uh
circadian clock rhythms uh and then I'm
back up at two and then I'm two to
twelve I need at least like a strong 30
minute nap where I start you know like
crazy crazy all right one other thing
we're gonna do we're gonna play a quick
speed round about the morning since you
talked about the mornings all right what
time do you wake up 2 A.M
2 am 7 A.M every morning how many times
it might be three if I'm dragging a
little I mean I don't go to sleep till
like nine I gotta get to three I gotta
get those six hours in how many times
you hit snooze
twice if I hit him more than twice I
don't hear it no more really I'll go
into a deeper sleep first one hit snooze
once then I hit it twice and I got to
get up off that second snooze I love
that first thing you do in the morning
uh meditate drink go drink a liter of
water then meditate wow a liter of water
get like before I get out the bed the
leaders right there I got it down it
that gives me an energy to meditate then
obviously I gotta pee I get that first
person you text
oh I usually don't look at my phone
until after I work out when I'm working
out that's when I text my mom my mom
texts me these Daily Devotional
affirmations from Joel Osteen and I tell
her thank you I love you have a great
day every morning that's a perfect way
to start yeah when you get into the
shower what's your go-to song that
you're singing oh man Ain't No Stopping
Us Now or Don't Stop Believing
okay that's great shower music
foreign